Yeah.
Somebody asked,
what's up with all the lending teachers in your house and then how is it to look
at them every day?
Well,
about
in 2001 you to see it of manic collective insanity.
I decided to start seeing if I could find Soviet era artists ox online,
mostly through Ebay.
I had read a paper by James Pennebaker who claimed that uh,
past events start to become historically significant about 15 years after the,
after the relevant event.
And so 2001 was 15 years after the fall,
essentially after the fall of the Berlin Wall or close enough.
And so I started looking on Ebay to see what sort of Soviet artifacts or might
be able to find.
Um,
first of all,
I was kind of curious about what would be available for purchase.
And I also saw it as deeply ironic that the most free market of,
of what would you call platforms ever device,
which would be Ebay could now be used to scavenge communist era artists,
Alex from Russia.
You know,
it just seemed like to be someone who was raised during the Cold War.
The fact that that,
that I could buy things like heads of Lennon on Ebay was just too comical to not
to pass up,
you know.
And so I started buying things that I had some familiarity with because of what
I'd read historic.
Again,
the first thing I bought was about a three by five silk flag that was awarded to
a factory for meeting its five year production quota.
And I don't know what you know about those infamous quotas,
but what would happen is that there were dicta sent down on high,
but how much factories were supposed to produce and the implied,
um,
what the implication was produced or else by any means necessary.
And so two things happened,
three things happened.
The goods were often shoddy because they were rushed.
There was deception about how much was actually produced and then people were
radically over worked and under supplied.
So it was a bad about and system.
But it was very interesting to actually have one of these flags and see what
they were like.
And then I bought a block,
a stainless steel plot,
windup clock that was a submarine clock.
And it was bomb proof.
So I thought that would be handy if someone ever bombed my house and I needed to
know what time it was.
So I bought that.
And then I found this painting that's actually off to my left here.
It's five Russian revolutionaries,
all younger and court stalwart looking,
standing on the edge of a cliff with a red soldier or a white soldier off to
decide they're all shackled together and he's preparing to execute them.
And that was,
uh,
that was,
a fairly common Soviet motif.
And,
um,
on my right side,
I have a,
a decorated Soviet war hero who's,
who's working in a steel foundry and like a lot of the Soviet art glorified,
I suppose the,
the working class.
And I suppose there's nothing wrong with that depending on the degree of
propagandistic intent and falsifications.
But,
um,
they're kind of like Norman Rockwell paintings,
except they don't have the same degree of sentimentality,
which is quite interesting.
And what's it like to have them around?
Well,
pretty much every square inch of my house is covered with paintings.
And a fair number of them are,
I don't suppose the sorts of paintings that people would usually have in their
house.
There are,
some of them are of the Second World War.
Some of them are strongly political and uh,
but it's,
it's,
well sometimes people say,
well I wouldn't want to live in a museum.
And I guess that isn't how I feel.
I actually like living in a museum and I like having these historical artifacts
around and I really like watching the propaganda and the art more in the,
in the paintings because many of these paintings were produced by very talented
impressionist artists who are trained in the classical European tradition.
They spent months making these paintings and yet their subordinate in some sense
to a political ideology.
But what's interesting is that as the political ideology recedes into the past,
the more purely artistic elements of the painting seem to remain.
And so it's cool to kind of watch,
it's very slow process,
but it's very interesting to watch.
The art itself emerged triumphant over the propaganda.
And then,
you know,
these things also remind me of what,
what I'm interested in.
And that's the study of videology.
And they reminded me how powerful ideology can be and how many different
pathways it can take,
two to,
to control,
I suppose.
And,
and,
and it also reminds me of the reality of the 20th century because it was a
terrible reality.
And if we forget it,
then we were likely to repeat it.
Now,
my kids grew up in this house and you know,
they,
I asked them about it because as far as the paintings are fairly heavy and maybe
even somewhat frightening,
but they really liked it and people that I had,
it gives me a reason to invite people into my house and gives me something to
play with.
And,
and I,
I guess I need things to play with by all appearances.
So that's the story of the,
of the Soviet paintings.
So.